oh what
why are pawns just circles
that's so exchange
and what is so i i actually understand
this
this is a funny i've seen
i've seen like beginners post positions
on
reddit with this pset
because when you're first learning chess
sometimes it's hard to keep track of
like how the pieces move
so like the the pieces are shaped in the
way that the
piece moves it's like rook is up and
down and sideways
the bishop is diagonal i don't know what
this is this is like just a
attempted l-shape the queen all
directions
the king with the hexagonal thing
the pawns moving straight forward
let's do one more
do i do i keep this set oh people want
letters
okay i'll do letters
uh yeah the people are speaking
oh playing strong player p sets
okay
oh this is this is gonna be so tough
i'll try though
um what is this it's just a circle of
blob thing oh we have a london okay
someone wanted this opening earlier
um that's not the best move
because i can take
i feel like i would rather play blind
then
look at this ugliness
no offense to whoever designed
these letters this is awful and i love
it
oh you're welcome
let's develop a bishop
um
i feel like playing scrabble now
but i'm i feel stuck because i don't
have any vowels
unless maybe these could be o's then we
can spell
like born or bonk
or bob
okay or bon cloud yeah
or oh barbecue but bbq is not valid in
scrabble
unfortunately it's a
yeah it's kind of a abbreviation type
[Music]
if thing video of my queen blunder makes
it to youtube then it's not a blunder
bitter
oh sacrifice for compensation yeah
sacrifice for content
i'll have to remember oh do i do
scrabble
i'm actually curious do people
when people want to see like one
scrabble game
before i end tonight
i really feel like playing scrabble now
like these letters like
i just want to spell words
oh people saying yes oh
oh smurry's sigo said yes
okay i just have to make it through this
[Music]
game
what oh that's a pin whoa because ours
move
in straight lines
but i can move back
and now my circle thing is attacking the
end
it spells on also spells noon
what's minori attack
also spells
[Music]
also spells oh no
[Music]
this is too much fun
play this move
now it's spelling no no
[Music]
okay
so the back rank is saying er but the
fifth rank is saying o
let's make it just say more yeah let's
accentuate the o's
and then we might we might just get oh
oh no
oh no no the queue is just chilling
it doesn't have a u
[Music]
unfortunately
it's so weird because i'm just seeing
the shape
it just looks like a sideways l
a very large sideways l
hmm
man i don't oh the wait no the pawn was
defended earlier
or the the o was defended
so the q wants to participate in
in the spelling
or just it wants to support the o's
oh okay
oh we could spell we were spelling okay
oh we could spell rook
oh
maybe that's uh the secret weapon it's a
spell out rook
and this guy is a little bit weak
make him stronger
that's a really confusing
i think i want to play this move it
looks wrong
but then
oh we have to be very careful
that was not a good decision let's do it
anyway
so i'm my my r and q is are gonna get
forked by the n
but then i play this
i just have an r rather than er
but the goal is to just
basically spell oh no
which kind of means oh yes
okay
i can't complain with this
hmm i feel attacked
you gotta use our action
oh we can also spell or or nor
which rhymes with f4
what is going on i'll just keep pushing
stuff
there's some kind of thing the q is
aligned with the k
there's a lot of alignment happening
this is
yeah a lot of pins and just weird things
oh my pawn play this move
this r is so lonely
hmm
my opponent's probably playing with like
non-letters
which is totally unfair
um ah my o is hanging
but what's happening here it could be a
draw
i don't know this could just end
really peacefully or really violently
depending
let's gain some time
okay pushing pushing the o
i just want to make another q
yeah i can move
or is it
okay
okay
oh
gg um that was a really weird game
analysis board uh maybe we should
we should flip back to see what just
happened there
uh
there we go okay back to normal it was
actually a really interesting
so i kind of okay the opening was fine
and then i mean
the fifth rank was nice
and then now i got forked but it wasn't
so bad because this
this n was a monster
this is so monstrous pawns were smiling
and then i actually don't know i really
thought it was going to be a draw
i was on the verge of just repeating
here but then i realized
this is just mating
and white doesn't quite have perpetual
so i'm curious where white went wrong
like maybe it's already bad here
oh white has to be very precise
so rook f1 only move that doesn't lose
oh thanks for subbing nando's something
something
appreciate that that will probably go on
youtube
yeah first time playing chess with just
letters
that was confusing that was probably a
one-time thing
i don't know if i'll do more of that
but maybe i'll do some scrabble
i could do scrabble it seemed like there
were there are a lot of people
asking for scrabble i am like very into
scrabble
i play a lot actually off stream
so anyway this is scrabble i'm not gonna
play blindfold scrabble
okay oh playing a strong player so this
is uh
i thought i selected blitz maybe i
didn't
so this is a five minute game
uh first thing i see is like possibly
tomato but not quite if the c were in oh
i would have tomatoes
i have mascots so like mascot could be
here i think i'll just do that
i got the m on the triple
um
i'm looking for seven letter words here
on untrue so usually like
u's are the are the worst vowels
um this is just a dumb vowel so
if i can get rid of both use in one play
that would be nice
so um
i should also note i have i i know all
of the the two letter words
oh but opponent blocked me yeah those
two letter words would have been valid
um i might just play like
man i want to use i would just want to
make a short j word
so there's jew for 20
i think juntz might be valid no or john
play john
okay if there's an open end
okay that the end is open but it doesn't
quite fit thinking reuniter
we're also playing a version without oh
i forgot to have the chat
we're playing a version without
challenges so i can check if words are
valid
yeah reuniter doesn't quite fit
unfortunately
uh
what else do i have i've i have too many
vowels
um i have units oh i have uniter
oh no but i don't have that the end
i should have played jut
okay but opponent so opponent just used
three vowels so they were probably also
vowel heavy
we can see how what tiles are left
uh what to do so i could play something
like true
the next play is not going to be high
scoring
i'm thinking about just playing uniter
and then leaving myself with some
something to score with
yeah let's play uniter
okay
i have some words here
okay so opponent use uh the triple for
the f
um so i have irony
but i can't quite fit it there so re is
only
two letter r word that works here and i
have
i'll probably end up doing like yen i
guess
so i have the over like over
i'm just curious if over tiny doesn't
fit anywhere
no that's not valid anyway
hooray
i think i'll play yen
35 points it's a very close game very
close game
yeah so if i get if i use all seven
tiles then there's a 50 point bonus
that's called a bingo
and that's usually what i want to work
towards um
so i want to leave myself with good
letters to
oh wow so opponent got the x on the
double
letter and the triple word so it scored
60 points
very nice play
so i could just put this here
for 22.
is h0
so you play this let's play that
okay so i scored 27 um
yeah exora i really am familiar with
this word
i think there's also there's some like
definition command
sora
oh maybe i i would have to investigate
further
but i'm playing a good player who
probably has studied
and studied some of the must-know words
[Music]
so the board is closing down which is
not good because i'm behind by a lot
i'm also really low on time
i'll play bird alexa
is the bird the
the word bird bird bird is the word i
knew it
alexa play bird as a word
the bird is the word by the ruffle
feathers on amazon music
alexa quiet
ah i don't know what to do time is
ticking
is is jacob hurt
oh
no oh thanks alexa remind me again in
a half hour
alexa thank you
okay that's not too bad i'm only down by
50 points
oh i appreciate that only down by 50
points
board's very close oh is birdie
is birdie with a y okay that's not valid
otherwise a y could score really well
here
um and us yeah nasa could score a while
too
i really want to do like four for
trade
check for data
hmm
okay component doesn't score much
um i'm just going to play oh ford is not
good
um
i could play todd and dad
so if i if i fall below zero then
i i get one extra minute but i i would
lose 10 points
as becoming very difficult to play okay
now
i'm disappointed that birdie is not
valid like with a y
now it's really difficult to play before
no no i might just like throw
like make small words like hope
i have i maybe maybe ave is
ad is probably my next play
if nothing drastic happens
i also have um you and eem
opponent's time is taking two
so yeah when you go negative you get one
extra minute then if you lose
the one extra minute you you lose the
game
so i might have to go for the dirty flag
so both blanks are left
[Music]
plays ahi oh i wanted to do that earlier
let's play this word oh i have the z
z is a good scoring tile but it's hard
to
it's really hard to find a place for it
um
[Music]
art is valid but
what else to do
i think i'll just play ut oh let's play
the eem
11 points
so uni is valid so if i had like ti i
could make a longer word
[Music]
oh opponent takes that spot let's play
at oh biota is valid
okay i'm up on time
uh let's just play biota so i have a
blank
i think to win this i'm going to need to
use all seven tiles
uh towards the end get rid of the z
and it's really closing down this is
crazy
opponent passes that's funny trying to
make me
lose points uh can i play
llamas point keep
keeps passing by i have to keep scoring
man it's so hard
uh
i have the blank but what to do with it
let's change
i don't see the way out
clamas
oh envy's there we go
trucking trucking trucking trucking
let's go back in the game i died one
point
qu i don't see what to do
you oh i'm stuck with the q
that's not good oh opponent has great
letters too
i'm gonna lose ah retweet or re-wedded
crazy game i almost came back
i was proud of finding envies to like
open the board
like envy's set started trucking
beautifully
it looks like retweeted the opponent had
such
a good tiles i was stuck with the queue
again
i was trying so we can analyze
i don't know if i missed anything i was
trying to find a word
with q u
i'm not seeing anything
like there's really there are not so
many options
i could check it's retweet retweet oh
retweet is valid
yeah google is also valid some words
have been
added to the dictionary
yeah kwop is not good i don't believe
um there's a word q-o-p-h which is valid
it's i believe a hebrew leather that
somehow made it to the dictionary
oh chi you achieve
maybe cho you but no
not quite